ils étaient des milliers ce week end à
se rassembler dans le centre ville de la
capitale des lycéens en colère avec une
revendication principale
l'établissement d'un nouveau système
scolaire des jeunes qui ont formé leur
propre groupe surnommé des mauvais
élèves parmi les points qu'ils défendent
la refonte des programmes l'égalité le
droit à la parole ou encore
l'assouplissement de certaines règles et
de principes conservateurs du royaume
des revendications soutenues par les
parents d'élèves qui n'hésite pas à
accompagner leurs enfants lors des
rassemblements
si le gouvernement est sincère dans sa
volonté de résoudre les problèmes ces
étudiants auraient déjà dû recevoir des
réponses sur la manière dont le
gouvernement va réformer le système
éducatif mais le gouvernement ne les
écoute pas alors je dois venir et
montrer mon soutien à ces étudiants
avec les problèmes que nous avons dans
la société actuelle il serait étrange
que nous ne prêtons pas attention à ces
questions nous parlons de ces choses à
la maison mon enfant veut se joindre au
rassemblement et je veux aussi savoir à
quoi ressemblent ces protestations des
aînés au chevet de cette nouvelle
génération thaïlandaise qui s'opposent à
des normes très strictes notamment
vestimentaires et qui réclame au passage
une réforme de la monarchie actuelle et
la démission du premier ministre en
place depuis 2014
le premier ministre justement qui est
monté au créneau jeudi dernier en
assurant qu'il n'hésiterait pas à
prendre des mesures plus drastiques pour
freiner l'élan contestataires il ya un
risque d' escalade vers plus de violence
si longue et remédie pas cela pourrait
nuire au pays et à la monarchie bien
aimé le gouvernement va intensifier ses
actions et utiliser toutes les lois tous
les articles
pour prendre des mesures contre les
manifestants qui enfreignent la loi
les mesures seront prises conformément à
la procédure judiciaire du pays est aux
normes internationales
la semaine dernière six personnes
avaient été blessées par balles lors
d'affrontements entre des manifestants
d'un côté des policiers des ultras
royaliste de l'autre une affaire suivie
à la loupe par berlin qui se dit prêt à
remettre en cause le droit octroyé au
roi thaïlandais de séjourner sur son
territoire si le mouvement démocratique
était écrasée par l'armée où les forces
de sécurité et si des personnes ont été
tuées alors je ne crois pas que le roi
de thaïlande pourrait continuer de
séjourner en allemagne la thaïlande dont
le secteur primordial du tourisme est
déjà en difficulté à cause du coc u19
pourrait connaître d'autres jours
particulièrement tendue dans les
prochaines semaines